A CPAC was mostly worthless.
The second day was a complete throw away.
Nothing worth covering happened on the second
day Saturday, which is good because I was
in bed with a fever from my second coronavirus
vaccine dose.
I wouldn't have been able to cover any of
it anyway.
Fortunately, in a sense, there was nothing
worth covering.
But one theme that sort of wound its way throughout
Friday and Saturday and Sunday is that CPAC
attendees were unwilling to accept that Donald
Trump lost.
We are, what, just a few days short of for
December, January, February, March were days
from being four months beyond the election,
which Joe Biden easily won more easily than
the margin by which Trump won in 2016.
And CPAC speakers, I guess because they're
still sort of kowtowing to Trump, placating
Trump will not admit that Trump simply lost.
Let's go through some examples.
Here is Tom Fitton from Judicial Watch.
This is one bizarre guy with some kooky ideas
saying Trump had the votes on Election Day,
but vote totals changed as ballots were counted.
Can you imagine?
Take a listen.
On Election Day, President Trump had the votes
to win the presidency.
These vote totals were changed because of
unprecedented and extraordinary counting after
Election Day.
Now, in a literal sense, what Tom Fitton says
is true.
Votes that were cast by Election Day were
counted after Election Day.
Legally, as always, happens with absentee
ballots.
And as those votes were counted, the results
changed.
Yet that is in a technical sense, it is true.
He wants you to believe something illegal
happened.
Of course it didn't.
Then Larry Kudlow, Donald Trump's former economic
adviser, talking about polling from last October.
He's put we have ballots that we counted.
Now, you talk about polling beforehand.
But Larry Kudlow is talking about polling
from before the election, comments on that,
I was interested last October, a Gallup poll.
Said fifty six percent of Americans.
Believed at that time that they were better
off than they were four years ago, despite
the fact that they had been in the pandemic.
They still believe that they were better off.
That's a Trump thing.
And then Josh Holly gets a standing ovation
after reminding the crowd that he voted not
to certify the election results on January
6th, this was part of what incited the violent
riot.
And the crowd gives Josh Holly a standing
ovation.
You know, on January the 6th, I objected during
the Electoral College certification.
Maybe you heard about it.
I stood up.
I guess the crowd believes that they are being
principled in some way by giving Josh Hawley
this standing ovation for an action, Hallie's
action, much like Ted Cruz and others that
melded with Rudy Giuliani's trial by combat
thing and all of this other stuff.
And, of course, Trump's speech saying let's
go to the capital and led to a riot.
The crowd cheering it.
Then Matt Schlapp, who runs the American Conservative
Union, that's the organization that organizes
CPAC, saying that what happened in November,
it was an unconstitutional power grab and
leaving CPAC, it would be do all you can to
any member that we have any influence over
to explain to them that it's unacceptable
to have this unconstitutional power grab on
elections so that what we saw this election
will be what you will see every single election.
And we have to fight it now.
It wasn't an unconstitutional power grab.
It was that Joe Biden won.
They still can't accept it.
And why should they?
Trump still hasn't accepted that Hillary got
more votes than him in 2016.
It's been five years and Trump doesn't accept
those results.
So, of course, they're not going to accept
the results from almost four months ago.
Since they think they won, they won't be changing
their strategy either.
And here's House minority leader.
Gives me great pleasure to say, Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy laying out the plan.
Listen.
We're going to continue to do exactly what
we did in the last election, OK?
I mean, if you think you won, I guess you
do the same thing.
And they are also, as we talked about earlier
in the show, planning to suppress more votes.
They're already scheming to do it.
We gave you a report earlier in the show about
253 different bills and measures to suppress
voting across 43 states.
Republicans believe they won.
I guess certainly they don't want to change
their strategy, but they didn't suppress enough
votes and that's what they're going to try
to do now.
One last hilarious moment.
This is this is my favorite right side.
Broadcasting is one of these online based
right wing channels.
I don't think they're as big as Newsmax and
on, but they're big enough that they're worried
about getting sued.
And CPAC was rife with anti science discussions
related to covid and rife with anti fact discussions
related to the election.
Rightside broadcasting during a CPAC panel
discussion about the election cutaway to read
one of the funniest disclaimers I've ever
heard to try to protect themselves from legal
liability.
Three different states.
Forty two thousand votes, forty five thousand
votes, something like that.
And we would have had an Electoral College
vote of 269 to 269.
There's a lot of sensitive topics being talked
about right now.
We want everyone to do your own research in
regards to what they're talking about in the
discussion right now, anything with the election
or anything like that.
So it's important to do your own research.
I know there's several outlets here that are
able to completely broadcast all of this content
for you with any disclaimer at all.
But unfortunately, here at Rightside Broadcasting,
we must jump in here and put a small disclosure
that we want you to do your own research.
And it's very important that you do that.
Yeah, absolutely.
Just quickly, although we are broadcasting
these speakers, we want to provide you with
that, it does not mean that we necessarily
believe or support all of their beliefs of
every single speech.
Speaker talking to you to make sure that you
research everything.
You talk to your health care physician positions,
whether it's regarding covid or medical information.
And if it's election related, just look it
up, look everything up.
And we are just not endorsing any speakers
for the event.
Again, we are simply broadcasting these speakers.
Talk to your health care physicians.
There's so many election lies and so many
bogus medical claims being made at CPAC that
Rightside Broadcasting has to cut away an
issue, this absolute gold disclaimer.
And at one point, they also they interrupted
Mike Lyndell from my pillow during an interview.
I'm not even going to play it because it's
so stupid.
But they interrupted and said, you know, we
have to be really careful, Mike, because we
could lose our entire thing.
And Mike Lyndell said, oh, you can find that
clip if you want, like an extra bonus clip.
But this is where my coverage of CPAC ends.
We're going to take a quick break.
We'll do more vaccine stuff after the break
and many more things.
Glad you're with us on this first show in
March 2021, The David Pakman Show at David
Pakman Dotcom.